(guitar music)
- [Voiceover] Dead Kevin
- Yeah and then on our
way out we actually ran
into my ex girlfriend
who got super fat.
- Nice!
(laughter)
- So that was, it
was a good night.
It was a good night
to say the least.
- Yeah everyone
from my high school
is still playing beer pong,
so I just went home early
'cause it felt dumb.
- Yeah, I get that.
- Alright, well I'm gonna
hit the sack early guys.
I'll see you when you get back.
- Alright.
- Cool.
- Alright, night guys,
- See you soon.
- Night man.
- You staying up Ryan?
- Uhh, yeah I'll stay up.
- How many games of beer pong --
- Wait, hold on a second Ahmed,
I think Jack didn't,
I think he just minimized us,
I don't think he turned us off.
Hey Jack!
- Oh yeah, Jack,
you're still there!
- Hey Jack.
Oh, he muted us.
- What is he doing?
- Jack.
What the hell's he doing?
- Jack?
Jack!
- What hell's going on.
Jack.
- Jack what are you doing!
- Oh boy.
Woah.
- No, Jack, what are you doing?
- Yeah, he's masturbating.
- Jack!
- Come on!
Don't do that!
- He is masturbating.
- Come on man, we see you!
Ryan, do something!
- Alright, I'm gonna call him.
- Ryan turn it off.
- I'm gonna call him, I'm
calling him right now.
(sighs)
What the fuck?
- That's our couch.
- He just ignored my call.
You serious?
Just, Christ man.
(groans)
- Oh man.
- He's not gonna stop, Ahmed,
might as well just
enjoy the show you know.
This is it.
(groans)
Look at his face!
(laughter)
(groans)
Woah!
Wow.
God, good for him man.
Good for him.
He's wiping it on the cushion.
- What?
- He's wiping it
on our cushions.
Wow.
- Guys.
- Hi.
- Did you see that?
- Yeah.
- So, your ex
girlfriend got fat?
(guitar music)
There's nothing wrong
with masturbating,
everybody does it at this age.
Why don't you just like and
subscribe to our YouTube page?
- And leave a comment in
the comment section telling
us about a time when you
got caught masturbating.
What's up dude?
- Hey how's it going man?
- Is that semen?